hey everybody okay let me get everything
up here I was so close to being ready I
was seconds away from having everything
I needed go and I just didn't quite get
there but I'd rather have you hear me
ramble for a minute or so well I feel
the time rather than be left waiting oh
my god when's he gonna get here which I
mean is the call that I make I don't
know if that's actually preferable from
the perspective of any of you folks but
that's what you get okay
cool cool cool cool nice oh okay
before you read player games you might
want to google and read a blog post by
the author called a few notes on the
culture gives a lot of content for the
books universe I might do that because I
actually did start that um okay sending
some good thoughts and love to you all I
hope you all are all having a wonderful
day if not I hope your day gets better
that is a wonderful sentiment thank you
oh the Hufflepuff in scotland hey
everybody
okay let me get my notes because I have
notes this time I'm skimped on that the
last few times but I but I actually have
some now ended notes just being like
things that I mean to bring up at some
point and have frequently forgotten so
this time trying to you know do it
better
Oh TV and sin on a different channel
Whovian Rap Battles what are you up to
that is an interesting sounding project
how you be I be okay this week is better
than last week was but as I noted to a
co-worker a filing cabinet could've
dropped on my head and it still would
have been better than last week was but
you know improvement is improvement so
I'll take it
love the vids thank you very much ooh
toreador in London mm-hmm I love the
people are tossing out you know Hogwarts
houses vampire the masquerade tribes
like oh this is great uh take what you
can get yeah yeah pretty much can you do
a Scottish accent um I could try but I'm
also not going to cuz I I feel like I'm
just it's just gonna end up being
insulting like mice my god a Scottish
accent amuses my seven-year-old boy
nobody needs to hear that what game is
in the n64 oh I think yeah still Mario
Kart 64 in there uh he wouldn't need
scotch
ha ha ha but from New Hampshire Oh
doctor who guide hey there I like the
color of your shirt my which which sure
the one underneath or the or the button
up but yeah I I suppose means I get to
show that off so am I now actually on
the on the teespring storefront I just
put up the inverse on this with the
genders fluid the nerdist constant you
know flipping it around so if this
interests you but you kind of like it
said the other way that's now available
Hey plug in my stuff almost like someone
who knows what they're doing is crazy
slithering baby oh yeah do we have any
Rafe and pops now like if you're gonna
do the house split Liz is probably a
raven puff um like she's kind of almost
everything except Gryffindor I think
we've actually discovered just described
her as the the Huff the puffiest little
slither claw over sure the the tea is
nice I
Ravin got Raven door hmm almond rigged
hufflepuff from Maryland best house
splits is clearly slender claw so Oh
something that I meant to do last time
but I literally it was it was buried
under a pile of other stuff so I forgot
I was sent I know a book this one
actually written by subscriber this is
Alex Baxter Scott and their book trauma
so I don't I don't know what I'm gonna
get to it but I have received it and the
cover is very cool and the description
is interesting so I do want to get to it
but time it's that thing that there's
literally no such thing as enough of
Washington earthy child for the first
time last night was plated pret
pleasantly surprised at how watchable it
was yeah that thing holds up like the
the eventual it kind of comes
immediately after I get think they've
kind of labeled it as 10000 BC or
something like that that's fine but
unearthly childlike has a soul of peace
really good I watched shot a yesterday
I'm assuming you mean the the animated
recreation because there are multiple
options for what you could have meant
there take your 10 and take your time
400 pages this one hell of a thing to
get through if anything else it makes an
excellent doorstop well thank you Alex
for that recommendation as well so it
can it can pull its wait until I get
around to it
and southern New Hampshire last summer
we had our first Pride Festival and
it'll probably happen again this year
any chance of you attending um it it
would depend on the date on the very
specific date because and this happens a
lot like that this is why I almost never
have any free time I have my my kid
every other week so that and and for the
whole weekend because her mother and I
trade her off on Wednesday so that we
can each have you know complete
weekends and what that means is you tell
me that something's going on and there
is literally a 50/50 chance that I will
look at my calendar and go no I have my
daughter so can't do it so I'm not gonna
make any promises the other thing is
like money's really tight right now I'm
I'm gonna be I'm gonna be recovering
from taxes for a little bit so I mean
I'd like to I would love to go to more
stuff in general you know pride and cons
and oh okay I don't they I mentioned
this time I did I have gotten the
tickets for cons this year it's gonna be
terrific on in Connecticut that's
confirmed tickets are bought and
Gallifrey one next year which if you
didn't already get tickets for probably
sold out by now but that is thanks to
patreon support and the people who
support me on here like I couldn't do
this stuff otherwise so that's that's a
big deal just like Captain Marvel in the
cinema today that's cool that it's still
in some cinemas like even with with
endgame coming up like quick that's very
cool
if I can find out the date how soon
shoot you a message on here awesome that
is totally cool so yes
so speaking of endgame I'm not gonna get
to it this weekend I'm not gonna get to
it till next weekend and that's by
choice I could see it sooner than this
but the thing is I really want to watch
it with Liz we didn't get to see Captain
Marvel together but the last few Marvel
films we got to go to together we went
to infinity war together we went to
Black Panther together I would really
like to see his with her and to my mind
like I don't think people are waiting to
see the movie until they hear my review
so I don't think it'll be the end of the
world if I don't get it out until the
until like a week later and honestly by
that I'll probably be safer for me
about spoilers doesn't mean they have to
be very careful on the internet for
about a week but we'll see
could yo to block Wizards spells like he
did with force lightning that's a good
question because you know Yoda was
walking something physical whereas with
Wizards spells there isn't always you
know a tangible bolt sometimes there is
depends on what the spell is so for my
money Yoda could could block and sort of
take and disperse anything that like
shoots a bolt of some kind of energy he
can cope with that but if it's like I
don't know if it's a sleep spell of
transmogrification like somebody who
doesn't shoot something at him maybe not
that's a tough a call Shazam was good I
like Captain Marvel but preferred Shazam
yes Shazam myself in gandu and I don't
know when I will with that one I think
there was a fire by kitchen but I'm
enjoying this stream too much to check
the kids should be fine yeah yeah it's
not a problem
don't worry about it seriously though
you smell smoke just go check I'm gonna
be here for like another 50 minutes it's
fine
uh who do you think would win in a
battle Yoda or the master in the end of
time um probably Yoda just because the
master doesn't really have firm control
over what he's what he's slinging around
in that one what are your opinions on
series 1 of Torchwood ah it's really up
and down it doesn't really have any good
episodes until a ways into it and even
then they're kind of sporadic there's
like hey bug like I torchwood to me is
only good on occasion when it is good it
can be very good but I mean Torchwood
got off to a really bad start the the
second episode of Torchwood day 1 I
it's like I think it's atrociously
unforgivably bad see a painting on
season 2 a strange with things I'm not
gonna bog down the chat with that cuz
I've got a video up for that one so you
want to know my problems with season 2 a
strange things cuz that's mostly what I
talk about you can go check that out
uh do you watch Gotham yes and when the
show ends the end of this week I will
put up an overview review of season 5
and also once it's over Liz and I are
gonna do a top 10 characters from Gotham
joint thing we've we've been planning
that one for a while so that'll be a lot
of fun I'm kind of like what we did for
or for Buffy a little bit ago have you
seen any doctor who edits I don't think
so cuz I'm not entirely sure what that
means twelve minutes and and no drinking
game questions yeah I think they've
caught on to us and actually I don't I
don't have I don't have anything with me
um that was something I didn't grab it
was too busy setting this up I do not
have beverage damn no that's empty dang
it okay have you ever watched
Supernatural I have not
bunch of slackers tonight ah
quite possibly that's not a social watch
this cuz I'm supposed to do homework
how's it going look I'm not writing you
a note for your teacher okay just own up
to whatever the consequences of this are
have you seen the expanse nope let's you
prefer brenão Cheers
there we go go go grab a drink we'll
wait what did you think of a cabinet
meeting and children of Earth the one
where the position I mean children of
Earth just overall is great
I actually think episode three is a
little bit unnecessary but overall that
miniseries I'm not even gonna bring it
down
by episode or scene-by-scene but like
that's that's really good and I need to
revisit it one of these days I'm nervous
too because the last time I watched it I
didn't have my own kid so I'm kinda I'm
kind of worried about getting wrecked by
it now so what we'll see want to help me
with my homework no like what of all the
things in adulthood that I don't care
for the fact that my job doesn't follow
me home that's a big one
so no homework and I'll past hold on I
did have nose here hang on let me get to
some of these okay so here's a random
tidbit that I just find funny at this
point you don't have the Disney Plus
streaming thing is gonna be launching
towards the end of this year roundabout
and they're how they're putting
basically everything on it like the
entirety of Disney and like all Star
Wars and Marvel and all the shows
they're gonna be producing and all this
stuff bunch of Fox stuff you know what's
one thing that they've confirmed is not
gonna be going up on their song of the
south it's not gonna go up on Disney
Plus which is so funny to me because
song of the south at this point it's
almost more infamous for the fact that
Disney just won't release it again then
for what it actually is and it's really
weird because like it got released to
theaters like as late as the ad I saw
Song of the South through the theater
auto re-release run so if we all know
what it is we all you want to know what
song in the South is we we all know what
it is so the fact that they're
continuing to try and hide it as if we
don't know that it exists and what it is
rather than do what Disney themselves
did with their like war propaganda fell
and what Warner Brothers did with some
of its stuff that has not aged very well
and just said look understand the time
in the context is this was released we
understand it's not okay now but look
here I don't get why they're still
running away from this thing I really
don't it's so weird to me
he needs to react to Sabrina um I yeah I
have not seen Sabrina liz has she liked
it pretty well but a big part of why she
liked it was she had watched the first
season of Riverdale before that and she
hated aren't you so much
she likes Sabrina way more than a lot of
other people that I've heard from I have
heard that there are a fair amount of
lgbtq+
elements in it so I am curious for that
but like it's I don't I don't I haven't
sets set aside time to do it yet back
classing canceled culture for Disney I
don't think they're hiding it they're
probably trying to be you know a better
company well see the thing is I honestly
think the streaming platform would be
the perfect way to release it because
since the streaming platform is you pay
for the streaming you get access to
everything it's not like they're saying
here's this shameful part of our history
give us money for it the way that they
would with a DVD or blu-ray release
putting it out on streaming is the
perfect opportunity to basically just
cleanse the whole thing and like I said
to put input I was gonna say a warning
like it just claimed or at the front
like Warner Brothers did with some of
their data stuff like with this other
stuff cuz right now it just seems like
they're afraid of it which is weird I
find it strange
um I don't care why you took issue with
are you wanting to have sex before she
dies it's not like she's doing it to
impress anyone okay yeah a lot of people
seem to misunderstand me I don't think I
explain myself very well on that I do
not have an issue with Arya making that
choice I don't have an it's not like I
think Arya is innocence I like know for
you preserve
very rigid is like I don't care or she's
an empowered woman she can do whatever
she wants
there's just something about that
specific sentiment the the sentiment of
I don't want to die a virgin and it's
like it's a relatable one I'm not
judging her for having that sentiment I
don't think this Sully's the character
anything there's just something about
the use of that as a trope that rubs me
the wrong way I don't know how to
explain it any better than that
so I I feel like I explained myself
poorly I'm not sure I did much better
over here but I feel like I expressed
myself poorly in my review because a
number of people like seemed thrown off
by my issue there and didn't quite get
where I was coming from and I should
have been I should have like made it
clear that this was not something where
I could go look I can explain to you
exactly why this doesn't work in why
this is problematic this was just a case
of it it just rubs me the wrong way and
it's just something about that sentiment
and I don't even know why weird hang on
my own headspace there you go oh oh side
boob of course yes I oh dear how many
folks is is buffering four it's it's
showing us okay on my end
Torchwood shouldn't return new no it
should not I see you have swords I have
a theory that you are a secret 2000 year
old warrior from a distant planet you're
planning on taking back your home from
the evil Jackie Tyler from Doctor Who oh
dear
it's uh it's an interesting theory
combed through all my videos see what
see what supporting evidence you can
find that's not me trying to
artificially pad out my views by telling
someone to watch all 900 plus videos
maybe you want a more substantial reason
for people to get together I'm not sure
I do
though like I don't have a problem with
their being like just because they can
and like I said I I cannot explain why
the specific sentiment of I don't wanna
die a virgin rubs me the wrong way maybe
maybe it's just because I've seen too
many um like like oftentimes cheesy and
often meant to be likes keep like the
single only character out as a scumbag
I've seen in things where like that's
used as a line like some guy being like
this could be our last night on earth
you don't want to die a virgin do you
and like I think just something about
that sentiment just skeeves me and and
like almost regardless of context so
like I don't think there's a deeper
reason reason it just me I'm looking
forward to the Utopia review yep that's
tomorrow hope it's good because I love
the master arc if you've already done it
and I missed it I probably look stupid
no I mean I've shot it it hasn't come
out yet comes out tomorrow
what do you thought on the fantastic
four movies from the 2000s I don't mind
the first one insofar as there wasn't
really that strong a superhero template
yet you know Spiderman had come out so
and they kind of knew oh we can show
some of the ridiculous stuff in the
comics and they tried for that but it
didn't quite work the second one I
actually find really insulting not
because it's worse than the first one
it's actually probably on about the same
level but the fact that they didn't
bother trying to improve anything it is
all the exact same problems the exact
same issues they just did it again
they didn't try and improve they didn't
try to learn they didn't try and refine
they just did it again and I just found
that insulting this is gonna sound
random as hell or or it would if it
for the surname but do you like ER b
stands for epic Rap Battles of History
I've seen a couple and like this fine
it's just not really my bag I'd like I
enjoyed the ones I saw they just didn't
like they didn't click enough with me
that I felt like I wanted to see more ah
I don't view it as I don't want to die a
virgin I view it as this is a big part
of human experience I don't want to know
what it's like like again it's not like
I I'm gonna get off this topic just cuz
I don't know how to better express it
like there's all these things to people
like oh are you like this about it I'm
like well no I'm not but it still
bothers me so like I don't know I just I
just need to I just need to leave that
alone at this point did you see class I
caught in Netflix and enjoyed it was
amazed that Doctor Who spin-off snuck
past me I haven't I haven't seen class I
missed it during its initial run and
just never got back to it and then when
I heard it was cancelled I was kind of
oh well maybe I don't really need the
bother favorite MCU movie who might be
spider-man homecoming that's a tough
call though for me Doctor Who is a
childhood memory and this is why I can
never leave the show what is the reason
you love the show because of the
possibility of it it is about someone
with a magic box that takes them
anywhere in time in space it can do any
genre it can be set in any location it
can be set in any time for me there's no
reason for that to ever end because it
can literally do anything uh how about
the Orville's still haven't seen past
the first few episodes again issue of
time will you make a video on the new
Godzilla trophy ah that's what I forgot
I meant to check to check that out
before this livestream happened I know I
probably won't do a video on it but yeah
I meant to watch that son of a gun oh
and speaking of spider-man um homecoming
it's C
cool spider-man far from home is
officially going to close out the phase
three of the MCU so for those keeping
track Phase three started with Captain
America Civil War it will run through
spider-man far from home which means it
will comprise 11 films phases 1 & 2 were
only six films each so they they've
strung this one out for for quite a
while um I started reading it do you
mean you've already started reading the
player of games are you finding it
confusing I mean I yes I have started
reading it I haven't gotten very far
into it and no I'm not finding it too
confusing it's so far but then again
like I'm not that far into it when I say
I just I mean like today I have just
started reading it um let's see do you
like Rick and Morty no no I don't I
don't enjoy the character I understand
why people like Rick and Morty it's a
very smartly written show um I you know
I'm not I'm not gonna say it's bad but I
don't like spending time with these
people so no I don't enjoy it
any advice on coming out um it really
depends on your specific circumstances
um and who you have in your life to come
out to because that's the thing coming
out is not something you do once it's
something you do in stages continuously
for a long time so see if I can run down
my timeline real quick I came out to
anyone at all for the first time I was
20 um I came out to my mother I was
probably 26 maybe um came out to most of
my friends around 30
and my back
come on back yeah there we go
huh shinobi I don't know what's up with
my connection tonight uh boxers are
brief boxers like briefs I don't I've
never really much cared for thought the
buffering was just me know it know it
even have it on my end I had to
reconnect for the day we you know would
actually have to come out and people
just be people Oh Kim that will what a
glorious day that will be buffer the
life buffer the live stream Slayer ah
love it
I never understood coming out I just
live my life and let people realize it
um
I mean a lot of it also I mean part of
coming out also you have to realize for
a lot of us is has to do with we go
through periods of our own
self-discovery
so like especially if you're any sort of
what is 10 what tends to be thought of
as a typical gender variant you know
transgender gender queer gender fluid a
gender by gender etc the a good portion
of us don't really understand what's
going on with our sense of gender like
for a long time so coming out is usually
something that you have to do if for no
other reason than you were living your
life vit visibly as something that
you've realized oh that's not me and I'm
not saying you can't just start living a
different way that fits you better but
people are gonna have questions if if
they've been used to you living one way
and you begin living another that and I
don't mean that in like a you owe
everyone an explanation but I mean like
people are just gonna
have questions they're gonna be confused
so like I said coming out is if if you
can live a life where you never have to
bother even doing it you just get to
live that's that's a thing of beauty but
that's certainly hasn't been my reality
and it hasn't been the reality of the
vast majority majority of lgbtq+ people
that I know at any rate do you like
Steven universe still haven't seen it um
[Music]
what's your favorite insert song or
background theme from Doctor Who you
mean like current theme or like just
music track cuz just music track it's
the greatest story never told from the
two-parter in the library from series 4
I knew that my daughter was genderqueer
before she came out but it was still an
important step for her yeah and that's a
thing too like I think it's a fairly
common thing when you come out that
people who know you pretty well will
roll with it pretty well because there's
a decent chance that they're like they
either knew or like I knew something was
up but I didn't know the specifics but
they're waiting for you they're waiting
for you to be ready to talk about it
as a bi woman married to a man I really
need to get the I'm not just an ally
t-shirt oh is that a t-shirt that'd be
very cool yeah listen I had this
conversation um actually just when I saw
her this this past weekend about how how
annoying it is for her that she doesn't
she doesn't clock as queer to people
because she's she's she's kind of had
she's kind of had it with with certain
people like assuming that she's you know
a completely straight heterosexual
cisgender and is in no way any part of
the lgbtq+ community when she is and
like that just bugs her at this point I
kind of feel bad cuz like I think if if
my hair is down I think I think I read
queer in some fashion so and like it's a
bit of a relief to sort of know that
yeah you kind of paint people's radar in
that way do you think Hercules will be
in the Eternals
I mean maybe has even been associated
with them like I don't know a lot about
the Eternals been out for 40 years now
though my understanding of who I am and
how I describe it to others keeps
evolving as I learned that's actually
that's a big thing Raven and like I
might at some point probably over on the
veer a wild channel devoted specifically
talking about evolution because I think
the narrative for a lot of lgbtq+ people
and certainly a lot of people who've
fallen under the trans umbrella the
popular narrative is that you sort of
always knew that you were something
other than what you were assigned in
birth and that certainly has been the
experience of some but it wasn't mine I
didn't grow up feeling wrong I don't
have dysphoria and getting to where I am
now has been an evolution like I don't
think I would have thought - or even
been able to live the way I do now five
years ago definitely not ten years ago
so I don't think that what you see
before you right now is something that I
always was but it was just it was
repressed know what I am now is what I
have arrived to and what I will be at
some point later down the line could be
something else completely and it's it
helps my frame of mind to sort of just
be open to that
to whatever's next
today I'm watching Avengers end game and
I'm super height hope you enjoy it
keep spoilers very very very far away
from me what was your dream job as a
child I tried being comedian but people
can I think ask me like once I was old
enough to like understand what certain
jobs involved I wanted to be an actor
like at a real young age I wanted to be
a paleontologist because it was as close
as I was gonna come to seeing a dinosaur
but have you watched contraptions nope
don't know what that is oh oh you mean
contra points oh yeah yeah yeah I've
seen her stuff she's great um what's
your favorite series of Doctor Who mine
is 1 4 or 5 I mean my favorite series of
monitor Doctor Who series 4 that hasn't
that hasn't changed I was a stand-up
comic five years ago Oh whereabouts
Donna
cuz like I tried my hand at stand-up
comedy in New York and I don't know if
it's still like this but certainly at
the time that I was there it was a
rigged system that was designed to prey
on the people trying to break in to the
business it was uh it was it wasn't fun
nice oh thank you nostalgic I thank you
very much so is very wild an lgbtq+
channel or is a more channel for those
who enjoy cross-dressing at this point
in time new material that go up there is
primarily discussion
lgbtq+ related stuff that doesn't tie
into geeky media because that stuff goes
up here um what the veer wild channel
would chant veer wild channel I can
speak was originally was cross-dressing
advice
so like the backlog is heavily that sort
of thing um but the newer stuff that
goes up there which is not that frequent
I do a new video there like maybe once a
month um
that is much more broad lgbtq+ topics I
had kind of hit all the major
cross-dressing topics that I wanted to
and I just I'm not saying I'll never
talk about cross-dressing type stuff
again I just had kind of burned through
all the stuff that I really felt was
pressing that I wanted to get to oh hey
there Tracy thank you have you ever seen
something wicked this way comes the 1983
dark fantasy from Disney I haven't I've
read the book um but no I actually I
haven't seen that um oh yeah I was a
cutthroat business so I went back to
dental hygiene in writing yeah yeah it's
stand-up comedy what stand-up comedy was
like in New York when I was there and
again it may have changed I don't know
but when I was there which was almost it
was about ten years ago now if you were
not if you couldn't be introduced as
you've seen them on Comedy Central
Presents or on X sitcom if if you
couldn't be introduced with that kind of
like preamble or credit then what you
were forced to do in order to get any
time on anything vaguely resembling a
professional comedy stage well is what
we call bringer shows and what those
were was in order to get your time on
the stage there had to be a certain
number of people in standard was five
had to be five people who came paid the
entrance fee at the door cited you
specifically as the reason they came to
the show and also bought the drink
minimum so in other word
they were using the people desperately
trying to break in to the business to
pad the audience numbers for the people
who were already established because
like I said if they could introduce you
with any kind of you've seen them on TV
you didn't have to bring people um but
if you didn't then you did and like
speaking personally I wasn't gonna ask
my friends to pay door admission and
drink minimum to come and see the same
act they've already seen me do like and
even if I had new Act a new set for
every single time I performed I still
wouldn't ask them to do that like I mean
they were as broke as I was so like yeah
rigged system I'm a professional
assassin for hot here take a look out
your window for proof um how do you feel
about River Song and why by the way
heart oh thank you Anya um I like River
Song I think um that in some way she
does exemplify both what Moffat is good
at and what he's not good at which is
that I love her banter
I think Moffat does banter very well I
like the timey wimey meanness of her
storyline and the nonlinear nature of
her relationship with the doctor it
often time it the emotional resonance of
her rings the truest in her very first
appearance and in subsequent appearances
since then it's a little bit more and
like if it works at all I think that's
much more down to the performance from
Alex Kingston than it is from the
writing because I feel like Moffat kind
of struggles with deeper emotional
resonance he kind of understands on a
mechanical level how it should work but
he's not that great at pulling it out
and I do feel that that kind of happened
with river over time so I still like her
but I get why she bothers other people
man 1 I need you to choose a race to
take part in man to relay man 1 yes
really
oh god ow Ben that was awful
Oh who was your doctor I don't really
have one
like the one that got me interested in
watching the show was Tennant but I'm
I'm still really hesitant to label
anyone as my doctor I just rarely deal
in those kinds of definitive --zz are
you watching the prequel show of Game of
Thrones
I mean maybe um when it comes out
whatever it ends up being I'll check it
out briefly I suppose
do you prefer Jerome or Jeremiah Jerome
like I don't I don't get I don't I don't
get why they did what they did on god
this is a god there's a Gotham tangent
for anyone who didn't know what I think
that question was a reference to like
Jerome was just more fun and I liked him
way more Jeremiah he's all he's gotten
better but like he was way more boring
like and I get that angle on it where
like the emphasis was much more on the
intelligence and sort of the the
planting end of it which has gotten less
of a of an emphasis lately but I just I
don't enjoyed our mind nearly as much
when you come out to people do they ever
say something like you're not a trans
woman and you're attracted to women I
don't get what you're coming out ass
well I it's hard to say cuz I haven't I
haven't really had to come out in a
while and at this point the people in my
life are people who do get it like I've
been very fortunate in that I don't
really think there was anyone who was
particularly close to me who was going
to find it really weird or get thrown
off by this like slightly confused some
questions maybe but like not
not uh not a hole so wait a minute kind
of conversation I haven't really had to
do that how do you feel about the rise
of Skywalker teaser I did a video on it
so go check that out I'm far less
enthused than most people seem to be
green light a new Marvel or DC movie for
a character not yet shown in the
franchise which would it be
Kamala Khan and if I could greenlight a
TV show it would be she-hulk
uh I'll always love the man in the scarf
he was the first one that meant so many
years ago but I have to say I'm fond of
them all well yeah I mean that every
doctor is somebody's doctor even the
sixth is somebody's doctor although I
feel like that's a more legitimate
position with the Big Finish than he
used to be are you looking forward to
his Dark Materials TV series not really
I'm not like oh but like I never read
the books and from like what the vibe I
got off them in like the half of Golden
Compass that I saw I'm like I don't
think this is for me and like I say that
even understanding that the golden
hompless compass was not a particularly
good adaptation of that but it's still
like the whole vibe of it I'm like yeah
I don't think this this is my bag
did you see a TV show named Graham I did
I did about four episodes of that um it
was solid enough I just didn't hook me
enough to keep devoting my time to it do
you have any tips for making Doctor Who
reviews um well you say you're
struggling I guess it depends on what
you're struggling with I mean all I do
is sit down and talk about what I
thought about a thing I mean what I
don't have I don't really have advice to
give what I do is exactly what it looks
like five is my doctor will have words
no I'm like I'm not that's great that
you love five I don't sorry but that's
great that you do I like Jeremiah cool
awesome I'm happy for you I still really
don't but there you there you go um we
used talked my laptop to the TV to watch
Grimm because we didn't have cable
that's how much I liked - oh nice
great rigging it up old school who is
the best pony I'm assuming you mean in
terms of like my little pony I don't
know like I'm friends with some really
big fans of my little pony but I do not
know because I have not really watched
it uh twelve is my doctor capaldis mine
eight is mine four is my first doctor
yeah love love people sharing that what
show did you think had a great premise
but a poor execution and can do with a
reboot ooh
that's actually a really good question
but one that I'm probably not gonna be
able to come up with an answer for off
top my head but I might steal that for
like something down the line do you
think CW TV shows are better than Marvel
um
taken collectively as a whole
I'd call it a wash because like there's
really only one CW show that I really
like and I'm still sticking with and
that's legends of tomorrow and Marvel
like did - phenomenal seasons of
television and one pretty good one then
the rest of it was varying degrees of so
you know I I don't know have you heard
the books of Song of Fire and Ice know a
book that literally has to have a
glossary at the back so you can keep
track of who these people are
intimidate to me more than slightly did
you get a physical copy of player of
games or go with eBook um I thought that
one I went with
ebook like when I did monsters regimine
got a physical copy cuz like honestly I
haven't really read e-books like that's
a very new thing for me to be even be
trying to do so I'm basically kind of
trying to get my head around doing that
better with with this one so we'll see
someone should show you the Wheel of
Time
I mean I'm familiar with The Wheel of
Time I used to have to shelve that
series back when I worked at Barnes &
Noble so I know it hey my favorite sonic
voice actor I will never understand why
Sonic the Hedgehog questions keep
popping up sporadically like hey it's
not my fandom like has never been about
the games not the cartoon it's not the
comics like I never got into it so
favorite episode of Red Dwarf um where
they found him marooned let's see hold
on let me check my notes
I'm realize they have been going for a
while now oh okay here was here was a
weird thing I'm I'm starting to get
nervous about Netflix like in the like
in the long term so I haven't talked
about this kind of stuff on the channel
all that much I used to talk about more
back when I did go home Hollywood you're
drunk podcast this was the kind of thing
I'd talk about but it does interest me
so I'm gonna bring it up here so Netflix
has basically gone into debt another two
billion dollars in order to fund its
forward plans now the thing is they
already had ten billion dollars in
outstanding long-term debt so they're
now up to 12 billion dollars in
long-term debt this is the seventh time
in four years they've taken on
additional debt totaling more than
billion dollars out of whack and they
have a rather significant chunk of of
money you know spending obligations on
the books like in the 19 billion dollar
range there's gonna be due within the
next five years and they haven't paid
down any significant piece of their
outstanding debts so I really I really
kind of wonder and worry that the Disney
Plus thing is gonna end up ultimately
being a much bigger blow to them than
[Music]
that I initially thought because
initially I thought well you know
they'll just be a competitor but Disney
Disney is the Charles Foster Kane of
companies
they can release a streaming patent
platform and they can afford to lose
money on it if they feel it's important
enough Netflix is so deep in debt right
now which like it worked when they were
undeniably the top dog because they
could count on we dominate we will
continue to dominate we can get there
but knowing how big Disney Plus is
probably gonna be it's going to I don't
think it's gonna knock them inherently
out of the top position but it's gonna
knock them out of what is a very
comfortable lead position in streaming
and if they don't have that these debts
could kneecap them in a way they
currently don't when they're on top of
the pile and I just really worry that
they just took on a bunch more debt
rather than trying to solidify their
standing you know from a financial
perspective like in preparation for what
Disney's gonna do it's yeah Disney might
buy Netflix they bought everything else
no they won't because they have the the
farc steel cable the major stake in Hulu
so if they're gonna buy anything they're
gonna buy Hulu they can they can
outspend netflix so yeah it's it's weird
don't think Disney can legally bind
efflux well it's demeaning huh things
have gotten much more relaxed 'days
achill in terms of how big companies are
being allowed to get versus what it used
to be so I mean who knows at this point
favorite Powerpuff Girl Buttercup Amazon
could try to purchase Netflix you know
given that Amazon Prime is decent but a
very small piece of the pie
honestly that wouldn't be a bad move for
them to make I wouldn't mind seeing ads
if all or at least most of the content
is free liking crunch
Rolle what do you think um I mean I've
never used crunch rolls I don't have it
as a as a basis but the thing is like to
my understanding crunchy roll has always
had the ads but with Netflix it's really
hard to stick ads in when your entire
subscriber base is used to not happen
about like that's a much harder sell are
you a fan of child's play Chucky movies
I've only seen two I saw Bride of Chucky
which was fun and I saw a seed of Chucky
which I completely zoned out during um I
haven't seen any of the earlier ones
like horror France like slasher ish or
franchises like that uh-huh really my
bag there are like a few select ones
here and there like specific films that
I will enjoy for one reason or another
but I'm not really big on most of those
franchises but like there's there's
certain entries in say Nightmare on Elm
Street that I like there's certain
entries in well there's one entry in
Friday the 13th that I like you know
there's certain entries in the aliens
there's the vet the first jobs no but
you know things like that but like the
franchise I don't stick with these
things these long-running horror things
would Redbox teaming partner wouldn't
that flake speak too far of a stretch I
don't know because I don't know how firm
Redbox is standing in the first place is
did you like the time of the doctor it
is my favorite regeneration story well
then I hate to break your heart but no I
really don't like tell me the doctor at
all which is a shame because I really
like 11
have you seen bound Oh have I seen bound
yes and it is so so good
I actually I got to watch that for the
first time in just last year with Liz
cuz she'd seen it but she hasn't seen it
since college so if if you
if you've never seen bound if you have
any interest in lgbtq+ films at all you
haven't seen bound which was the first
movie that the witch house keys did Oh
check it out
it's uh oh thank you Edward
my voice did a weird thing there um I
already thought yours was one of the
most eloquent and well-balanced
pop-culture analysis channels on YouTube
but more recently you've helped me find
peace with my gender identity oh my gosh
that is that is wonderful to hear and
and and thank you
I know like it's still I've heard from
people like because like the for a while
Channel old even older than this one is
so I've had people sporadically
intermittently you know saying this
helped me that video helped me for a
long time but it never stops being
amazing and like kind of blows my mind
so thank you for sharing that and thank
you in quiet knightshade i've always
wanted to see bound yet make make time
Gina Gershon and that movie may well be
the single sexiest thing just walking
into a room like oh and like I very
rarely describe anything as sexy it's
like it's a it's a term that I'm very
like I'm not even sure I'm consciously
like cautious about but I just I very
rarely do it but damn oh man uh do you
think Jamie should have had to face
consequences for what he did to bran I
thought the Emma so it would be about
about that but brink
kept quiet I think under the
circumstances it makes sense that he
didn't because they are dealing with way
bigger things and bran knows that better
than anybody so it actually made a lot
of sense to me that that that that
happened you're very well-spoken I'm
envious much
respect for your GBC Q+ videos thank you
very much for that what water do you
have today I have a pina colada
I actually I forgot my water
oh thank you Gabe most important to be
true to yourself always oh my gosh yes
and even doubly so if it is taking you a
long time to even figure out who
yourself is huh what does John where is
it and is bound gorya bound is I would
call it neo-noir
it is not particularly gory there is
some violence in it there is some blood
in it but it's it's that sort of neo
noir detective steamy thriller kind of
thing did John row-wise is where it
lands get your water oh wait I know you
said that earlier but I just I I don't
want to leave you folks bound isn't or
yeah it's more of a modern film noir
what is the best cards you've played
when playing cards against humanity' oh
I don't know like that stuff doesn't
stick in my head um the way it probably
what if I was younger like cuz I can
still remember like really good dice
rolls in a D&D game from eighth grade
but I can't I can't remember cards
against the humanity yeah you're a good
place of that although I've recently
discovered um the game what do you mean
which if you've got the dirty version of
that that gets that one gets interesting
and also Oh joking hazard that one's a
lot of fun to do you have cards against
card to get smuggles that's a thing this
this is news to me I miss this saying
goodnight to the other Amanda Oh people
leaving if you get your water we'll all
be so I'll be sitting in your room
ah hey yeah it's uh I would recommend
bucket of doom it's another really fun
game like I'm gonna hang out more with
with my friends who have a like because
I have several friends who have like a
lot of games a lot of board and card
games like I've got some friends here in
the town where I live and I've got some
friends over like more in the area where
I do a lot of brunette and burlesque who
do that kind of who have a lot of games
and do that kind of stuff a lot I I
gotta get in on more that stuff cuz I
enjoy it um I don't I mean like even
this one basically was given to me by
somebody who had a duplicate says so
like I don't buy this stuff for myself
because I don't you know run these games
on my own but I do enjoy them when I get
the chance
have you gotten far enough into player
of games to know what drones are no I've
not gotten that far yet like I said like
dude I just started thing I recommend
unstable unicorns super-fun plus theirs
are not safer worth expansionpak like
that honestly that's a big selling point
if I can get a not safe for work version
like yeah let's get some friends
together we'll drink heavily and do that
that's that's always good have you seen
Doom Patrol I haven't yet
um I think I would like it but you know
again time I'm trying desperately to
like get into a rhythm of a film
production that might feasibly at some
point free up a little bit more time but
it's it's just hard I've gotta go to am
here going oh yeah Ingrid get get some
get some sleep thanks for for stopping
in though none of these games be Doctor
Who Top Trumps
on the Nintendo DS not familiar with
that one exploding kittens I've got the
same exploding kittens I dunno um I
think I only played it once but yeah I
dunno exploding kittens how often do you
perform burlesque and do you travel too
festivals I perform usually once a month
sometimes twice a month depending on
what's going on I haven't done I mean I
do the Vermont for Less festival because
I live in Vermont um but the I haven't
done a festival aside from the Vermont
burlesque festival since 2017 I did the
Montreal for Less festival think about
think about Burley festivals even though
I do enjoy them unless you're a
headliner you're not getting paid and
you you have to you have to do your own
travel pay for your own your own
lodgings like headliners get a stipend
people running workshops get a stipend
but if you're just there to perform it's
it's a money pit so I really kind of I
would love to do more festivals but I
I'm just not in a position to be able to
even afford to consider doing a festival
that's anywhere outside of a day-trip
Drive for me it's just not viable
have you seen the discovery season
finale I have yet to see any of
discovery killer Bonnie he's is great
god I just love the names of these
things are all burlesque 18 plus I mean
I'm 23 about I'm curious never been to
one uh as a rule of thumb yes um you
know largely just because of what a
burlesque performance generally is um
but also because of where they used to
happen I would say 18 plus is a minimum
a lot of them are 21 plus because a lot
of burlesque shows happen at places that
sell liquor or at bars with stage areas
so oftentimes the 21 plus unless the
unless the location will like let in
people under 21 but like makes them wear
a wristband or or or you know something
to identify that they're not to be sort
of drinks or what-have-you so yeah
pretty much any burlesque show is going
to be at least
18 plus if not 21 plus what's your favor
so bad it's good movie I don't really do
this so bad it's good thing I think I
need to add add that question to the
jury to the drinking game list of
questions because I feel like I get that
one semi-regularly I did a burlesque
show my shine coordinated self did not
have great time expand your comfort zone
they said yeah it's not for it's not for
everybody
like I gravitated towards burlesque very
naturally because I enjoy performing
like I I just enjoy being on a stage
like I will get on a stage for whatever
reason I can whether it is acting in a
play whether it is giving a talk whether
it is doing stand-up comedy whether it
is taking my clothes off in a burlesque
number give me a stage and I will get on
it so if you don't have like a natural
performer instinct you're probably not
gonna have a great time
that's at least not promenade a great
time performing it that said there's
plenty of burlesque classes out there
and I think even if you don't ever
intend to actually get on the stage I
think there's a lot of people that I've
known who take a lot of value out of a
burlesque class and finding it very
empowering just as something to learn
how to do even if they never do it for
an audience
good night
o night folks who are headed out
exploding kittens has a
not-safe-for-work pack too it's
interesting I'm in Ireland so it's rare
over here but one of my university
friends is a former never really asked
him about it oh okay so I guess my if
he's if it's if it's a he then he's
probably a boylesque performer which is
a pretty specific burlesque is divided
into like all these little crazy
subdivisions because you have classic
burlesque which is based off you know
how it used to be back in the day which
does a lot of rhinestones a lot of big
feathers big boas and not as elaborate
in the choreography you've got neo
burlesque which is and also classic
that's a lot of slow jazz you've got
neato burlesque which is a lot more
modern a lot faster pace a lot more of
an emphasis
on tight choreography and group numbers
you've got nerd lesk which is what it
sounds like is burlesque based around
geeky pop culture stuff you've got
boylesque which is male burlesque
performers it really kind of is all over
the place is burlesque inherently sexual
well yes because it's an inherent part
of a burlesque performance that you are
going to be taking some part of your
clothing off and that said a burlesque
number does not always have to be sexy I
have seen burlesque numbers that are
funny I've seen burlesque numbers that
are sad I've seen burlesque numbers that
are political statements I've seen
burlesque numbers that freaked me out so
they can be a very wide range of things
but as a rule of thumb the removal of
clothes is part of the story you're
telling
whatever that story may be so there is
always that element to it it could very
well be getting subverted you know or or
be playing you're getting played
straight but it yes it's always kind of
their love nerd list yeah neural ask is
is kind of uh yeah that's that nut
that's my lifeblood right there should I
say him Irish too now or your fan of
Brooklyn nine-nine yes I am I'm not
current on it but I like Brooklyn
nine-nine quite a bit have you managed
to watch any more of dr. robots since
you reviewed the fruit first two
episodes I have not yet I would like to
check it up but again you know yes time
somebody needs to invent more time
xenomorph burlesque ideas I'm having see
not as weird as you think there's a
there's a performer I know I'm in
America stearic she has a she has a
Jurassic world number with a puppet
like a little puppet of a raptor that
like bites parts of her clothes
it's like whatever you think whatever
idea that you think like oh that's too
weird for Pulaski no it's not not only
is it not too weird for a burlesque
there's a good chance somebody's already
done it like I do wonder if one of these
days I should like prep just a list of
sorry hang on guys give me a second I
got a I got a band somebody off here
there we go
cool awesome sorry about that um perhaps
a silly question but our nerd last
performers dressed as pop culture
characters yes generally I myself have a
number of nerd less acts I have a well I
have to Doctor Who acts that I've done I
had an eleventh Doctor act and I now
have a 13th Doctor act I have a poison
ivy act I have a Wonder Woman act nerd
less nerd nerd less I've done hosting as
ver I'd like I did hosting as Black
Canary I've got to be having a Star Wars
number next month
that'll be debuting oh and I have a have
a janine melnitz the secretary from
ghostbusters but specifically the
cartoon version of Jeanine I have an act
for that as well and there's probably
more than I forgotten you shout out my
friend it's his birthday his name is
Nick ger hey Nick have a B birthday that
is weird
it was distracted for a bit lost track
of chat what happened
apparently we've we've just gone into
into the burlesque chat corner over here
are you emotionally ready for endgame I
think I am we'll see does her Jurassic
world number involve never taking high
heels off no matter what happens well
yes her heels do not come off in that
number yeah see that that's what I my
favorite nerd leska numbers it's not
just a matter of like oh I'm I'm dressed
like this person and don't do it the
best nerd less numbers are really
informed by the character and the
property that they're emulating the best
nerd less performers love whatever nerdy
thing they're doing and they get all the
details right like to scary degrees
there's a there's a nerd less performer
named Ellie Quinn who is amazing she has
the most insane numbers she she has a
kirby number like a pink puffball it's
insane and she has a Hamburglar number
she's incredible uh see I would love to
do burlesque along with other dances but
I have CEP and use a wheelchair and cane
well here's the thing you said I have a
friend who who recently went through a
lot of difficulties and is currently
wheelchair-bound and she is planning out
a number that she will do from her
wheelchair so if you can figure out how
to do it then you can just get on the
stage bill burlesque community is in my
experience and not every single
burlesque community is this open but my
experience with the Burroughs community
is that it is the most open all are
welcome come and show us what you've got
artistic community I've ever been
involved in uh and again I'm not gonna
say there's no elements of you know body
shaming you have to have a really
specific thing like that exists but
that's never been my experience and I've
never had anyone as as open
you know collectively as an artistic
community as burlesque has been
basically the only rule of burlesque as
far as I'm concerned and this is the
Bible I've always gotten is don't have
acid whatever you do do it yo give it
your all but aside from that whatever
you want a brain somebody old somebody
will put it on stage Ellie is amazing oh
god yeah she is
very important question if suddenly a
flying muffin appeared what would you do
depends is it floating or is it like
zooming around so like I feel like my
reaction might be different depending on
that Hamburglar yes she has a Hamburglar
number Green Mountain is so
inspirational a Green Mountain cabarets
is awesome grumble why is there
grumbling I miss something
it has marshmallow wings and zooms
around um I probably treat it the same
as I would if a bird or a bat was in
here I'd try and shoot how to window
just because I don't know what's going
on with that but I don't I don't need it
in my house did you survive this the fan
oh snap why do you ask that we did the
Green Mountain cabaret just this past
weekend did their Disney Villains show
and by large it was Disney Villains from
like the cartoons and whatnot but we did
allow a handful of villains from things
that Disney owned so like there was one
Star Wars villain number there there was
there was a
how a number and there was a Thanos
number now I hosted that show or
co-hosted rather because it was me and
another host and what we did cuz at the
very end of the Thanos number the
performer was Alexa Luthor whose
fantastic at the very end of the number
cuz the number is her like with the
gauntlet and she keeps sheets you know
placing the gems as the number goes
along and at the very end she does the
snap so what we did is after she did the
snap and she exited the stage the other
post came on and I didn't and it's
always so we played it off like I had
gone in the snap and then when I came
back after the following number my
co-host asked me wait what what just
happened how did you come back and I
just throw in Shh spoilers it was it was
a lot of fun this burlesque chat is so
interesting yeah I hadn't planned on it
being this but I've enjoyed talking
about it after the stream ends I'll
comment the flying muffins story huh
your thoughts on honey and man Danis
theory um I don't think it would work as
I think Dan owes his body mass to dense
I honestly think that Ant Man would just
he tried to expand and he just get
crushed internally and I don't think it
would actually work it's gotta go it was
yeah good seein and I'm probably gonna
be wrapping up soon I've gone longer
than usual tonight but um but you know
I've just you know it turned into
burlesque chat and I love talking about
this stuff I'll tell you just watch for
it that's ominous what was the character
you liked identified with the most
growing up
I don't know like you'd have to narrow
it down like I could tell you like
growing up my favorite Star Wars
character or my favorite Ghostbuster or
like I can get more specific but like
broadly speaking I'm not sure I could go
that broad how did you decide on veera
instead of Natalie okay
funny story I might wrap up after this
so obviously Natalie would be the the
feminized version of my own normal name
which is Nathaniel um and actually in
like very early days of sort of getting
a handle on myself I and sort of mainly
kind of limiting myself to things like
online forums for you know gender
questioning or cross-dressing or
what-have-you
I experimented with a variety of
different names and one of them was
Natalie the reason I didn't stick with
that is because um my daughter's mother
who was my girlfriend at the time that I
started
excuse-me first like getting ready to to
come out in public
um her she was Vic she was very
supportive she always was and she
actually helped teach me makeup early on
but her sister her sisters name was
Natalie
so that weird that weirded her out just
a little too much for me to be called
Natalie um and so like coming up with
Vera was like a separate thing but like
Natalie got scratched off as a
possibility because of that um which I'm
actually kind of okay with that because
it's like I really like Vera at this
point so what I am goodnight oh yeah get
some sleep Jamie and I got a wrap up the
comic book at the top of the pile behind
your right side is the Spider Man coming
yes yeah no I had had this taken out
because some somebody called out like my
dislike of salad was Emma's art and I
had this readily at hand to try and show
people why I don't like salvus Emma's
art I mean like faces
look at a look at Iceman look at his
face I get so much crap for not liking
this guy's armed and I don't get it Oh
anyways here in Washington DC it's 4:20
a.m. oh really
Varys is a better name oh thank you
I think Veera suits your personality
better cool I'll take it
guess I would tell me why this guy
popped up in my feet what does he do
oh boy well Jonas yeah I'm wrapping it
up soon but long story short I have a
channel that's devoted to mostly talking
about geeky stuff like Marvel and Doctor
Who and Star Wars and stuff like that
and sometimes we talk about lgbtq+
representation so I don't know if any of
that lines up with what you'd want to be
seeing if not sorry
I'm a Massachusetts that's a 20 at night
yeah any particularly memorable dr.
Hoover a less ass act involving
regeneration see the thing I've only
seen a couple of Doctor Who eggs aside
from my own my my 11th doctor number
which I haven't done in years because
like the the premise isn't it kind of
outdated now I'll explain why so I did
my 11th doctor number back when Matt
Smith was still the doctor and I played
the 11th doctor and then I regenerated
into a woman which was kind of a novel
idea obviously now know so much the
doctor is actually a woman so like the
the number day isn't a novelty anymore I
probably won't ever bring it back but
that's okay cuz I have a thirteenth
doctor number now so it works out
suddenly a flying muffin beer what
didn't would these muffins man is this
is there there like a rift to the flying
muffin dimension did I anger the muffin
Lich is that what's going on
everybody loves the hair it has its own
fan club haha Thank You Carolyn for that
I appreciate that very much
who's your favorite Gotham villain I'm
tempted to answer but I don't think I'm
going to because that's gonna be like
spoilers for what I do for when Liz and
I do a top ten in Gotham characters do
you know the flying muffin man okay um I
think I am gonna wrap it up because I
have I have editing to do tonight so
that that I need to get cracking on so
it's been good this was fun I enjoyed
that it ended up going in this complete
other direction of burlesque and and
there's other stuff I have I have really
really enjoyed this that was a lot of
fun give a shout-out to my friend Sam
Mayer hi Sam
don't know you but hope you're cool you
and I are still gonna have words about
the fifth doctor bring it on
seriously read a few notes on culture
before getting more into the novel I
will I will do that
happy editing oops I love these
livestream does need to remember they
start an hour or earlier for me now oh
you don't have daylight savings nonsense
all right well good night everybody
thanks for tuning in thanks for watching
and sticking with me and eighteen years
since Shrek one oh good thanks for
leaving me feeling really old that nice
we're getting that jab in at the very
end all right
see everybody hope you have a good rest
of the week if you get to endgame and